the prerequisite for spending time with
any person is that they nourish and
inspire you
they feed your flame if you are hanging
on people who are haters who complain
who are frustrated who are always
blaming somebody else and guess what
you're gonna be you're gonna be the same
thing if your best friend is Debbie
Downer you're not gonna be as optimistic
as you can be rise and shine it's in
spresso time what's that belief nation
it's heaven my one word is believe and I
believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent adds
something and I want you to find it
embrace it and use it to make a
difference so let's start your day off
right together grab your coffee and sip
on today's message seek those who feign
your flames over to you Will Smith I
just saw this Rumi quote that I love set
your life on fire and seek those who fan
your flames the Phillie translation of
that is don't be hanging with no Jang
casts Joker's that don't help you shine
the prerequisite for spending time with
any person is that they nourish and
inspire you they feed your flame look at
your last 5 text messages are those
people feeding your flames or dousing
your fire put your phone down for just a
second and look around look to the
people around you are those people
throwing logs on your fire or they
pissing on it the people that you spend
time with are gonna make or break your
dreams everybody don't deserve to be
around you you got to defend your light
with your life so who are the people in
your life that are fanning your flames
shout them out tag on below I love this
video I think Will Smith is a hundred
percent right I think you are a product
of your environment I think if you look
at the five people around you or the
last I love the five last people that
you text and see are these people who
are fanning your flames and building new
or not if you are hanging on people who
are haters who complain who are
frustrated who are always blaming
somebody else and guess what you're
gonna be you're gonna be the same thing
but if you're around people who are
uplifting and positive and chasing their
dreams and guess what you're gonna
become
the hard part though I think is it's
it's it's how do I break free of my
environment how do I find these new
friends where do they magically come
from what I love doing and this is me
because I'm more introvert and so I'm
not really hanging around people I don't
get my energy from other people I think
aspirational mentors is a really
underutilized resource like if you love
Will Smith then hang around Will Smith
and and you can't hang around but you
might get an arrest warrant trying to
hang around Will Smith too much but he's
making content like hang around his
content that's the easiest way to do it
the extra confidence and belief a
momentum that I've gotten over the past
couple years is a direct result of the
videos that I am making and watching
consuming myself and so I think you can
look at anybody who look up to want to
learn from and put that into your
morning routine as a practical take home
I'd say don't just look at the past five
people you texted look at the last five
videos that you watched on YouTube were
they ones that inspired you were the
ones that built you up were the ones
that made you feel like anything is
possible
or were they stupid videos fail videos
just funny videos if you can shift the
amount of time that you're spending
entertaining yourself which is running
away from the problems that you have and
move that towards educating yourself and
learning because that allows you to
solve the problems that you have you
shift the amount of time that you spend
complaining and running away from your
problems to actually solving the
problems and getting better that's when
you start to win when the last fifty
videos on your YouTube history are Av
than 90% positive to you accomplishing
your mission and you learning that's
when you start to win and so a practical
example that you guys can sign up for is
my to 54 days of confidence where takes
up to two hundred fifty four days to
build a positive habit 254 days is why
people give up after a week it's not
working you got to wait longer the
average is 66 days but it can take up to
two hundred and fifty four days of doing
something every day for the habit to
actually stick so we created 250 for
confidence the link is in the
description below you can go and every
single
day for the next 254 days you will
receive a morning video that will help
you be confident basically you're
hanging around people like Will Smith
and Muhammad Ali and Tony Robbins and
some of the most confident people in the
world you get to spend 30 seconds to 5
minutes with them every single day this
is free you do that and you watch the
videos you will become more confident
and a goal later for me is to roll that
out to 54 of self love to 54 of believe
to 54 of all these different topics and
then also going each two topics to 54
for writers for producers for actors for
athletes for you know shoe entrepreneurs
all down the line
that being said I'm helping with 250 for
confidence you can make your own program
right if you love Will Smith surround
shop with him you love somebody else
ring us up with her design your life
stop being a product of your environment
and having your environment be an
accidental thing you get to choose what
you consume the Internet has opened up
your world you get to choose what you're
playing every day so choose carefully
choose powerfully choose the things that
fan your flames yes from the people in
your life and also from the resources
from the information from the videos
that you're consuming choose powerfully
now I've got a really special bonus clip
I think you're gonna enjoy but before
that I want to know who is the person
that fans the flames for you most from
our aspirational perspective somebody
that you've never met but somebody whose
content you just love when they do an
interview when they do a video when they
do a book like who is it that is that
person for you I would really love to
know please leave it in the comments
below and it also gives them some
exposure and some love so put it in the
comments thank you guys so much for
watching I believe in you I hope we
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
let's pray so give me go
one theme that I really people like yo
how do I build my self-awareness how do
I build my optimism how do I change my
mindset it's the people around you if
your best friend is debbie downer you're
not gonna be as optimistic as you can be
if the people that from your town that
you hang out with have no ambition
you're going absolutely nowhere if you
listen to your dad every day about how
the government sucks you're not gonna
love life you've got to audit your inner
circle podcast friends listen to me
listen very carefully to this mashup and
these thoughts because this underlining
tone of who you surround yourself with
absolutely fundamentally changes who you
are period and the story when I hang out
with some Silicon Valley in 2005 to 2010
I was a different dude when I hang out
in the agency land right now I'm a
different dude when I'm like it when I
was in college at Mount Ida different
dude like you're a different person and
I'm telling you right now this morning
podcast or this podcast because I know
some of you listen to Utley this podcast
if I can get one of you one person
listening to this to dump one loser
person in their circle and add one
whoever's that smiley happy person at
work that you don't talk to that much
that's at a cubicle around the way or
that awesome like that you don't how
everybody has like you have a friend
but their friend like went to college
with them you don't really know them but
like the three times you see them a year
the positive issue and like the doing
things surround yourself with those
people seek out your friends friend who
brings positive vibes and make them part
of your world and cut out your homie
from college that thinks the world sucks
watch what that addition and subtraction
does to your life
the biggest life lesson I learned from
my parents is you are the five people
that you spend your most time with so
whoever those five people are that's who
you are
you know that's a reflection of you
they're good habits and bad habits will
rub off on you and vice-versa so make
sure that the five people that you spend
your most time with is exactly who you
want to be because if you have a homie
and they're like oh yeah like I really
like them but oh man this one thing they
do is like really bad for them I wish
they didn't do it and I wait I don't
ever want to
it's like you wanna you want to monitor
the amount of time that you spend with
those types of people because regardless
if you know you might not believe in
something that they're doing regardless
that energy is gonna rub off on you over
and over again and the thinking that
they have of why it's okay that they do
it might eventually rub off on you the
road to the bag is definitely tied to
your team and the company that you keep
if you are surrounding yourself with
different energies that's not on the
same wavelength as you if they not
praying for you inspiring you supporting
you for showing you a better way hello
remove them immediately or you could
take them to church pray for taking the
church but you can't help them get there
though you got to take care yourself you
know what it's called it's like we
talked about the other day is like being
on the airplane and the thing come down
you got to take care of yourself first
you know then put the mask on put the
mask on really look at who you're
surrounding yourself with look who's to
the left and to the right of you it
ain't like minded are they disciplined
are they pushing you forward it's so
simple for us to solve this a lot of the
hardest problems are so easy to solve we
just have to take those steps which are
hard and be mindful of that because
trust me that energy is gonna affect you
if you're around thousand gangsters you
gonna be in jail if you're around
casters talking negative you're gonna be
negative if you're around some brush
you're gonna be rope broke fries pumped
around some month if you're around God
and some money you on your way you're on
your way you're on your way I want to
make some money I can't make I can't
really be successful by myself I need
other people around me so you where you
are as great as your team altruistic
world domination
honey Empire right I'm grateful I
understand why I'm here I think because
I am so open I wanted to think and see
it's a bloody brief life
all of you have the potential for
enormous success if you want to know
what garyvee DJ khalid oprah and others
know about empire building that most
people miss check out the link in the
description for a free bonus video